et je le disais vous vous définissez
claire opère comme une musicienne
soignante vous en parler d'ailleurs dans
votre livre qui est ici et qui s'appelle
le pansement Schubert paru en 2020 c'est
c'est bien ça le constat c'est de dire
que la musique un réel impact sur la
douleur tout à fait à partir d'une
expérience spontanée d'une résidence
démente dans un EHPAD dont la douleur
est diminuée radicalement à l'écoute
donc d'un morceau de Schubert d'un
extrait de de ce fameux thème de Landau
du trio de Schubert et bien j'ai fait
une étude clinique qui analysait plus
d'une centaine de soins douloureux qui
sont accompagnés par mon violoncelle et
on a pu conclure au bout de cinq ans en
comparant des séances avec et sans la
musique vivante au moment du soin
douloureux que la douleur des patients
était diminuée de 10 à 50%. il y a un
réel impact réel évidemment sur des
patients qui sont déjà pris en charge il
s'agit pas d'un si c'est un complément
thérapeutique mais extrêmement puissant
aussi bien sur les patients que sur les
soignants que sur les familles vous
allez jouer régulièrement auprès de
malade dans des établissements de santé
en fait je travaille depuis 25 ans à la
fois avec des grands autistes avec des
personnes atteintes de démence et puis
avec des patients en fin de vie dans
deux unités de soins palliatifs à Paris
et comment vous êtes dirigé justement
vers on va dire
cette fonction musicienne soignante
qu'est-ce qui vous a attiré là-dedans
alors je pense qu'il y avait un rêve à
la base de d'allier le monde de l'art et
le monde du soin c'était les professions
de mes deux parents d'ailleurs ma mère
était artiste mon père était médecin et
puis cette intuition aussi que la
musique peut prendre soin bien sûr
qu'elle ne va pas repousser les camps la
maladie grave elle ne guérit pas les
cancers mais elle va pouvoir transformer
elle va pouvoir remettre en lien
diminuer les douleurs diminuer les
anxiété et donc c'est une très grande
force dans un service de soins soigné
par la musique ou par des ateliers
créatifs de loisirs c'est quelque chose
qui se développe parce que vous il y a
encore du travail à faire là dessus je
pense beaucoup de travail bien sûr il
faut changer les regards mais j'ai eu
l'intervie j'ai eu l'occasion
d'intervenir au Parlement récemment pour
dire au parlementaire que un violoncelle
qui chante dans un dans une structure de
soins leur ferait faire de grandes
économies et vous qui êtes là dedans
depuis plusieurs années que vous voyez
l'évolution déjà il y a une ouverture
parce qu'il y a certaines maladies qui
ne peuvent pas être pris en charge du
point de vue médicamenteux et que toutes
les approches innovantes créatrices non
médicamenteuses en fait peuvent apporter
des réponses pour stimuler pour prendre
soin et la réponse est parlementaire sur
le sujet la réponse est une grande
ouverture alors je suppose que ceux qui
étaient là étaient intéressés en tout
cas c'est qu'il faut changer
effectivement le regard qu'on porte sur
les personnes malades sur la maladie
même on dirait peut-être jusqu'à sur la
mort et prendre conscience que
le patient n'est pas seulement un sujet
malade mais qu'il a toutes les
dimensions de son être dont on peut
prendre soin une musique apaisante moi
je prends en témoigner quand voilà je
suis dans une situation stress un petit
peu de musique ça relaxe je sais pas si
c'est le cas pour vous aussi moi
j'utilise pas musique moi je reste en
silence mais oui un peu de temps en
temps quand même pour pour travailler en
tout cas merci à vous claire opère
d'être venu en parler on rappelle
d'ailleurs cette date aussi demain avec
ce concert poésie qui sera proposé à
l'occasion de la Journée internationale
des droits des femmes ce sera du côté du
musée Maurice Denis ont peut-être on va
peut-être revoir le le site internet du
musée ce serait affiché en bas de
l'écran pour toutes les informations
voilà il s'affiche pour avoir toutes les
informations sur cette date